I think you should have the three worst
players back to play together against
you
just an idea okay well just tell me your
schedule because you would be on it hey
everybody welcome to another episode of
Rissa fury I'm so excited today because
I have on one of the funniest people I
know
jessimae Peluso I'm already gripping
what are you
I'm Eminem sheer panic because I feel
bad that you're gonna lose oh my god
Jessie Mae has been talking so much mad
[ __ ] yeah for like weeks now ever since
I asked her to do the show what's your
track record undefeated oh you are yeah
[ __ ] no one came close no really and
they were trying they also didn't have a
fanny pack they don't have a fanny pack
do they have this this grip ready like
I'm like let's get the show up do they
have the confidence button oh there's a
midden have the Stamos shirt there's a
lot going on here that's like an
x-factor that may be okay I just came
from a drunk aunt Fair it's like let's
do this broad sail ensemble oh oh yeah
yeah you come a talk show I know it's
your house you should talk [ __ ] no
nobody's talking as much [ __ ] I just
have a feeling like nobody's going to
lose as badly yeah Wow hi hello rudeness
a table for one you might know Jessie
Mae from her stand-up she's incredible
also her sharp tongue podcast which I've
been on which I love and we did an
episode of stand-ups doing makeup
together we did that we did a Beauty and
the Beast makeup challenge where she got
to turn me into Belle and I got a turn
and grass and to be into peace don't you
think it's kind of weird on her makeup
comedy show but she got to be Belle
shocker we did rock paper scissors which
we do actually does know how to do rock
paper scissor I didn't know how to do
that I don't know rules that's where I
fail in life is like the rules and like
you know just how things are supposed to
be done just little lay of the land
clearly from your outfit I don't
rules alright so we're gonna play the
first game pretty standard just a game
to five okay alright rules no spinning
no spinning like the top one just no
spinning okay we're starting we're
starting to panic okay look you ready
aim it in here Wow
you don't even know what your goal is
okay ready yes No okay go I'm going oh
there's more oh boy good D good D how's
your confidence baby I'm in a pure panic
I'm just I'm just gonna be quiet oh you
know you're not a son of a-- this all
happened so fast
take a moment No why don't you do it
here yeah okay is there any rules to
hitting it well generally you're
supposed to touch two men and then wait
a second and then move the ball forward
to prevent people from just like wildly
hacking at it oh I got a little pass
well Gible there you go there you go
you're good oh thank you
I was in Portland last weekend competing
in the Moneyball tournament in Portland
and I got second and women's singles in
third and women's doubles playing with
my mom so we just added some new
trophies oh are you humble bragging to
the guy into pure panic I felt that in
my ovaries like that's how it feels when
the egg leaves the fallopian tube it's
like yeah did I impregnate you in my
shot just a little just a little baby
kick you know III recognize skill okay
so touch touch touch touch now you can
move ball for good I have asked you Oh
how high are you right now I mean on a
scale of 1 to Andromeda pretty far up
there prettier but you know I had to
just relax yeah this is a stressful side
you know I just don't want you to cry
too much about a [ __ ] what's the score
is there a rule here just yep you just
move it till you can touch it yep we had
on Josh wolf who I got a bitter like
your
stoner brother mm-hmm you might want to
you know play some d fun do I get to
score that's on you I thought that you
were gonna let me win
no score put these up I see your little
skill level there thank you that's like
my comedy brother he is I feel like you
two are the like older brother and
sister I never had
I mean I've been the same way about you
and him Ashley him because I grew up
with a whole bunch of sisters so that
was Game one what's your score did you
just win yeah our fake game oh this is
very real was it 10 we played a five
time went so fast
usually it slows down when you're high
but holy hell I feel like I'm in 20 49
loser in this year so sorry but hey I'm
still gonna [ __ ] talk because you know
what you can't lose that right kind of
pointing at [ __ ] talking probably that's
maybe that's why I might even be losing
at that let's go do some handicapped
okay so you're gonna say some blow
that's a very normal thing to do on a
time so you grab a ball I grab a ball
okay I have to play this whole second
game only with my left hand
yes are you left-handed no yeah easier
for you okay so we're gonna have Jesse
made you something we've never done on
the show before but because you're such
a pothead and like love I mean I was
like that one I used sincerely big event
we're gonna have you roll a joint while
you're playing all right starting we're
starting you go okay okay yeah I
remember you guys start making that oh
my boo when do I start making it
whatever okay
yeah exactly gotta pick your moments oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is
Oh Oh aah
Mitch Mitch start making that joy okay
okay I promise okay just get away from
the dancers I can smell the weed yes all
right I'm starting to make this joint
I'm not even gonna pick off the branches
you got like a whole nugget there yeah
I'm going in I'm gonna eat it I'm gonna
smoke the whole thing I'm gonna Cheech
and Chong yes oh this has gone pretty
quickly very good Hey all right let me
write this up as hard as I thought this
is going too quickly so I need to slow
it down with this you smell it yeah is
it okay if I get some shavings on their
tactic move away the ball I suppose nice
smells nice stings the nostrils
pungent okay see if I can pass to myself
Oh see if I can pass to myself almost
what are we doing here now this goes
back to you can touch it oh Jesus Christ
something a little pterodactyl loose
yeah and it's never gonna happen
now you've angered me okay suck on that
mother [ __ ] it I just want to get like
rip [ __ ] drunk with you and get you to a
really weak vulnerable place so I can
actually beat you it just won't happen
and I love you so much but like you have
to understand I've been playing
literally my whole life since I was like
in diapers
there's no no amount of alcohol you
could give me that would change hi can
you patch me through to Kelsey's mom
please I want to know where secrets okay
great thanks but yeah I know okay bye
just calling my friend she works at
your brother I could well just showing
you guys what you can't do I'll give me
the ball back spinning feels so good
though I know but you just you can't man
[Applause]
okay folks focus just a week yes not you
just like okay you're not a [ __ ] you're
a really nice person one left I would
never go up girl except for in this
scenario okay to me I'm stuck in the
weed yeah that's why I thought I was
talking to you can I bring up a very
very random thing but we had scared
we had Remy Casimir on self helpless
podcast do you know who she is
no she hosts the podcast called how come
and she had not had an orgasm until like
six months ago
yeah she's adult woman had not had an
orgasm how old he 28 holy yeah is she a
nun and now no no just like it just
wasn't happening for her and then she
bought some toys like some very specific
toys I figured it out
but anyway I brought you up because she
said that the first time she actually
came she squirted and I was like
jessimae Peluso taught herself how to
squirt I did and I just feel like you're
a pioneer wow she squirted the fertile
ins whole time Wow 28 years didn't know
well it's been holding in there for so
long it's like yeah it's like literally
just natural geyser it's like I'm here
I'm here I'm a human I'm you know in
Oregon still that's amazing yeah yeah
good for her and I don't think you had
ever like how did you know you could
teach yourself to do that I figured you
know where there's a will there's a way
especially Google where there's Google
that's just info okay why just one but
um did that really just happen I got one
goal you did hey I was in the middle of
teaching squirting and I feel like
was just taking advantage of I have your
Gators got me to buy the foosball table
well I was trying to empower women I did
you all dirty I'm sorry I'm gonna smoke
that hole right now and just kind of
glide on through is that cheetah print
it is oh my god you have a problem with
it I feel like you don't want any
cheetah print which shocks me because
you're one most blonde in a few
different white-trash
you're not white trash you are a good
person well I think you can be a good
person and be white trash
can you I'm not competitive foosball
player is there anything more white
trash than bowling I have a trophy with
flames on it that's pretty
you have Guy Fieri's shaft up on that
shelf oh my god that is exactly what his
dick looks like we're gonna do two ball
which is where we each start with a ball
and you have to score both balls to get
a point does that make sense so if I
score a ball you score a ball it's a
wash and it only goes to three yeah and
if you win this you win everything but
that's not gonna happen but what's gonna
happen when you lose is that you have to
make out with your unicorn mask you're
famous Instagram unicorn mask you have
to make out with you your unicorn mask
for 15 seconds as if it's John Stamos
you think I don't do that alone on a
Sunday night after a bottle of wine and
catching up on Game of Thrones I'm I
wouldn't put it past you but I feel like
the world we have to China get a tongue
it I'm gonna go down like a goddamn
Viking so you just go ahead you set me
on fire and send me out on that River
because I'm gonna make out with that
mask
okay so right you ready so we're going
on one two three we're gonna have both
hit our goals ready okay one two three
[Applause]
your guttural sounds are just so
terrifying it sounded like I was calling
my Pegasus to come pick me up that's
what it sounded like are we going hey
one two three bears like a little weed
nugget on the table a jessiemae touch
okay
god I'm so loud cuz I'm in a pure panic
this is this legal I'm worried about
legality I can't even get the ball in
the goddamn did you win yet not yeah
that's - okay your wrist action is just
something to be wrote about in the
papers thank you I feel like you need a
New York Times article just about the
Rick's wrist action alone the only way I
can score on you is if I kind of cheat
at this point you should just let me
cheat a little my dad my dad used to let
me and he's dead don't be rude so you
have to let me cheat Oh bro dead dad
card okay course at this point in the
game you gotta toss a dead dad card what
else you gonna toss it I mean you did it
ha what's done is done
you ain't I'll let you spent I'll let
you spend don't don't don't you rub
don't you rub in my wound what yes oh
are you that what is that you need to
get that looked at medically that's not
normal it sounded like I called all the
geese in the country to come to me it
was a Yeti
it was a human mating call it was a
sasquatch mating call for sure and they
were just coming through the woods oh my
god okay sir one ball left
so one ball left I scored the first one
so this is
I am such a Lisa Simpson I'm a real
bummer loose dude hey good defense
that's a pretty good strategy oh god I
forget how like wild again some people
spin do you ever play where you just
spin like to have fun no I'm gonna do
this looking at you oh [ __ ] it and just
let it go in he didn't even try it was
like yep that was it
all right let's get that mask out okay
so do we have 15 seconds on the clock is
that all you got
do you want more no oh my god this is
gonna creeping me out how you're like
sensually caressed I don't know look if
I'm gonna like lose ya I'll clean it out
hold on a whisper secrets mmm does
someone's cell phone just ring John
Stamos is calling to order a little
better laughs do you feed is America
feel bad for allowing that was great uh
you know I don't feel so bad losing to
you I just didn't realize when I was up
against and apparently I'm up against a
damn foosball shark ya know I'm happy to
call you a friend what okay so black
where anybody can find you just plug
everything I'm gonna be crying in the
parking lot after this and googling how
to foosball cuz if I can learn how to
squirt by a Google maybe the same will
happen here sharp tongue podcast
chessy me calm i'm on instagram at
see maple ooh so I'm on Twitter at qui
cine and any any sort of purchase a
ticket or merchant portion of it goes
towards awesome Association amazing you
can follow me on instagram at Celtic
Park my website is Kelsey cook calm and
go subscribe to the self helpless
podcast thank you guys for watching
another episode of erisa fury be sure to
pick up your official erisa fury shirt
their buttery soft
I feel like dolphin skin they're amazing
be sure to LIKE and subscribe to the all
things comedy channel and you can get
the shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]